ahmet insel économiste et politologue
auteur de la nouvelle turquie d'air noan
du rêve démocratique est la dérive
autorités aux éditions la découverte
bonsoir achmed à issel merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors
tout d'abord sur ses rebondissements du
jour on peut appeler ça faisait comme ça
prenne le général haftar à respecter un
cessez-le-feu se rendre à berlin
ça dit quoi ça dit qu'on va vraiment
cette fois ci vers un règlement du
conflit vous y croyez c'est très
difficile de faire des prévisions parce
que les situations évoluent très
rapidement et changent très rapidement
quand vous avez constaté tout à l'heure
les jeunes l art art a quitté et moscou
ce sens signée qu'est ce qui s'est passé
entre temps pour que aujourd'hui il
accepte de signer nous ne savons pas
très bien les raisons pour lesquelles il
a eu ce changement de comportement
peut-être la partie russe qui le
soutient a mis une pression nous ne
savons pas mais en tout cas la situation
est devenue vraiment un champ de
bataille des puissances régionales et la
cultiver l'art ici et sont devenus un
peu les les deux puissances qui sont
derrière les deux les deux conflits les
deux parties en conflit
mais nous ne savons pas très bien les
les raisons pour lequel les deux parties
les la russie elle inclut qui sont en
face à face en libye
alors justement le président r doha en
turquie a déclaré aujourd'hui que son
pays allait commencer dès que possible à
faire des forages dans une zone
contestée de la méditerranée orientale
riche en hydrocarbures est ce que c'est
peut-être un début de réponse à votre
précédente question
poule à tulle qui effectivement il y a
entre autres raisons probablement ce
n'est pas la seule raison entre autres
raisons l'intérêt c'est cet accord qui a
été signé entre le gouvernement en jeu
connu par
le l'onu et la turquie pour la
délimitation des ombres d'intérêt
économique mais maritime est
effectivement comme l'accueil qui est
libye ils ont une petite fenêtre face à
face dans la méditerranée ils ont
utilisé cette spéciale fenêtre face à
face pour créer une zone une zone
d'intérêt économique mutuelle qui
empêcherait et je crois que l'enjeu
principal c'est là qui empêcherait
probablement la construction d'un
oléoduc pour porter ou un gazoduc pour
porter le gaz ou le pétrole le gaz
particulièrement extrait du côté de
chypre au bo large de chypre par là par
l'israël par la nulle part et par
l'egypte pour l'amener vers l'europe
puisque ce territoire va être contestée
c'est une raison deuxième raison est
évidemment ça peut être le pétrole
libyen qui peut être un intérêt
particulier qu'ont beaucoup de puissance
régionale je pense que les européennes
aussi ils ont cet intérêt dans en libye
le troisième facteur c'est aussi marquer
que la turquie est une puissance
régionale après la syrie devient un
acteur
qui et participe à des négociations
internationales alors l'envoi de troupes
turques 1 en libye pour soutenir le
gouvernement d'union nationale de l sa
rage à trois jours de ce sommet de
berlin sans ces réseaux de résoudre
cette crise quel message envoie ankara
selon vous l'envoi des troupes turques
et plutôt très modeste à ma connaissance
pour le moment ils ont envoyé une petite
cinquantaine à moins que aujourd'hui
s'est passé quelque chose que j'ignore
mais ils ceux qui l'ont envoyé au jour
d'aujourd'hui 50 à peu près du cadre
technique d'encadrement donc ce n'est
pas du tout des combattants en revanche
nous savons que la turquie a participé à
l'envoi d'une partie des combattants
syriens contre bachar el assad
il les a envoyés vers la syrie et par
dell la libye il nous ne connaissons pas
le chiffre mais ça compte par des
centaines et c'est cette présence fait
problème
mais de la même manière la russie aussi
envoyé à peu près des centaines de
milices ou de paramilitaires dans le
cadre de cette société wagner très très
proche du pouvoir us
donc du coup il y à vraiment là nous
avons une guerre par des mercenaires
interposés qui qui commence à devenir un
peu l'art et la nouvelle règle du jeu
oui est ce que vous craignez vous que ça
puisse devenir une nouvelle syrie ou au
contraire vous espérait beaucoup de
cette conférence dimanche à berlin
je ne pense pas que ce sera une nouvelle
série parce que dans cyril et dynamique
était très différente il y avait une
soulèvement une répression
il ya des conflits
religieuse des divisions religieuses le
pouvoir de bachar assad s'appuyer sur
une minorité
le cas de la libye est très différente
dans le cas de la libye ce sont des
pouvoirs tribaux qui sont en train de se
battre pour le pouvoir partager ou de
pouvoir partager les ressources de libye
donc il est plus probable qu'on puisse
atteindre en libye à un modus vivendi
entre thouars tribaux beaucoup plus
facilement que dans le cas de la syrie
je crois merci à vous et à remettre une
seule économie c'est politologue auteur
de la nouvelle turquie verdone du rêve
démocratique à la dérive autoritaire
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france